hello everyone hello everyone where we
go
good to see all of you so first question
well I guess I could catch you up on
what's been happening first in case
you're vaguely interested most of you
probably know or some of you know
anyways about what happened at Wilfrid
Laurier University this week or two
weeks ago teaching assistant named
Lindsey Shepherd was interrogated I
would say by the typical suspects the
kind of postmodern neo-marxist that I've
been talking about hauled her into an
inquisition and proceeded to rake her
over the coals for having the gall to
show a video that featured me about a
year ago on a Canadian TV show called
the agenda they accused her of violating
the criminal code essentially and the
Canadian Human Rights Code under the
provisions of Bill c16 which was the
bill I warned about last year and
accused her of transphobia and making an
unsafe environment and then they accused
me of being Hitler which was really
quite interesting because I've never
been accused about being Hitler so I
modified my my Kermit puppet here which
see you can probably see that I guess
and I've done a response video which I'm
going to launch pretty soon so this is
Hitler the Frog and the spokes frog by
the way and he well this is what we've
come to so all right let's answer some
questions I'm going to start with pigeon
hole which is the site that allows
people to vote on questions and so the
top flouted question is how do you I did
you testify a rejection of identitarian
ism when a pillar of the neo-marxist
strategy is to demographically replace
the indigenous people of Europe London
it's less than half ethnically English
okay so let's take that question apart
first of all it isn't self-evident to me
that it is specifically a neo-marxist
strategy to demographically replace the
indigenous peoples of Europe and I don't
think that's the strategy anyways even
if that's the outcome because you have
to distinguish between strategy and
outcome the strategy and principle is to
bring in immigrants to balance out
declining birthrate now I'm not saying I
agree with that I'm just saying that
that's what the strategy is and then the
next part of the question is predicated
on the assumption that identitarian ISM
is necessarily the answer to the problem
of the problem that's being identified
which is characterized as excess
immigration first of all we'd have to
figure out exactly what identitarian is
a means because it isn't clear if it
means radical right-wing ethnic
nationalism I don't think that that's
going to be particularly constructive if
it means having a sensible discussion
about what the appropriate limits might
be on immigration and to think about
that over the long run and also to have
a serious discussion about the degree to
which say Islam and and the West the
values of Islam and the West are
actually commensurate then that has to
be obviously has to be done but so I'm
afraid that to answer that question I'd
have to know more about exactly how
these terms were being were being
defined especially with regards to
identitarian ism because it's a vague
word and so that's all I can do with
that I lose my ability to think straight
or intelligently in confrontational or
unfriendly social situations any
suggestions for adaptation or
improvement well a couple I suppose one
is is that when you get nervous in this
kind of situation that you're describing
what often happens to people is they
start paying attention to themselves
they get self-conscious so you know
let's say I got self-conscious all of a
sudden
this QA what would happen is that I'd
start paying attention to the questions
and the screen and what I'm doing and
I'd start paying attention to how I was
feeling and to the nervousness and then
I'd start to get aware that I was not
responding properly and that would make
me more nervous and then I would get
more aware of that and that can just
shut me down entirely and that's
happened to me now and then in a lecture
and sometimes almost happened when I was
talking to Sam Harris the first time I
paused for a long time and then became
aware of the pause and then anyways what
you have to do in a situation like that
is it's not so much that you have to
stop attending to yourself because if
you start thinking I should stop
attending to myself then you'll just
think about yourself more what you have
to do instead is pay more attention to
the situation and to the people that
you're talking to so you have to
increase the degree to which you're
attending outwardly and that'll stop you
from attending inwardly that's a very
effective technique you can practice
that generally speaking every time you
get nervous start paying more attention
and that'll that'll that'll help you out
a lot yeah it's really good suggestion
for social anxiety in general is that if
you see most people but not everyone but
most people have enough implicit social
skill because they were reasonably
socialized when they were children so
that they do know how to act in social
situations but they get anxious and then
that interferes with them implementing
what they know just like if you're a
pianist and you get anxious and
self-conscious while you're playing
you'll forget what you know because
while you've activated a different part
of your brain if you can remember to pay
attention and you can direct your
attention outward and you attend hard
enough then what will happen and try to
put the other person at ease and try to
ask them questions then that'll kick in
the automatic because you're paying
attention to what the person is doing
into their facial expressions and all of
that that will
clue in the automatic and implicit
knowledge that you have and make things
much more smooth and and and anxiety
free so attention really attention
really plays a huge role in regulating
anxiety I would Laura tasks I would love
to hear you do a lecture series on
raising children properly is that
something you would consider well in my
new book mmm-hmm I've written a chapter
on that called don't let your children
do anything that makes you dislike them
and I've laid out a bunch of I've laid
out a philosophy of care and discipline
that's predicated partly on a French
philosophical legal notion which is do
not multiply rules beyond necessity it's
sort of like a legal equivalent talking
sir and an English common law principle
is which is use minimal necessary force
and I think the union of those two which
is don't have too many rules
but make sure that you properly enforce
the ones that you do have is a good
start for how you might consider your
attitude with regards to raising
children the other thing you have to
figure out is exactly what's your aim
and you know one of the aims that people
have had most recently pushed by
clueless psychologists I would say is
that you want children to have high self
esteem and that's actually a large part
trait neuroticism anyways but but and it
can be modified to some degree Jerome
Kagan has done some very interesting
work on that but
the best thing to do I think the best
thing to orient yourself towards with
regards to children is that you're
trying to make your child your children
or help your children to be delightful
in the eyes of others and so that means
they have to be reasonably well
socialized and that really takes place
between the ages of 2 & 4 because what
you want for your children is that when
they go out into public when they're
away from you or even with you for that
matter what you want for your children
is for other people to genuinely like
them because if they behave reasonably
and they attend properly to adults and
they know how to play with other
children then wherever they go they're
going to be um unless they encounter
someone truly malevolent they're going
to be welcomed with smiles and open arms
and that's not gonna be fake because
almost every human being actually likes
children if they're reasonably behaved
and so your job is to make your children
highly socially desirable because that
opens up the world to them so there
that's not a lecture series but it's a
little lecture looking at myself
honestly John says I'm deeply envious
and resentful of others happiness how do
I turn this around well John I would say
you've started to turn it on around
already because you have at least come
to the conclusion that you're deeply
envious and resentful of others
happiness so you do have the damn
problem diagnosed so one of the things
you might do is figure out what you
would like instead like how would you
like to feel about the world you know
because you're implying that being
deeply envious and resentful isn't for
the best so let's assume that you would
rather be pleased about other people's
successes and not envious well you know
the first thing you might think is well
maybe you have to do some writing or at
least some thinking it's like maybe the
alternative would be to happy be happy
about others success and happiness well
maybe you should start by thinking about
why you might be happy about their
happiness it's not like happiness is a
zero-sum game you know it's not like
it's not and I believe me I'm taking
your
seriously and I think that what you're
saying characterizes plenty of people
and I think that you're being deeply
honest noticing it happiness isn't a
zero-sum game you know lots of people
can be happy at the same time and do you
really want to live in a world where
other people are less happy would in
what possible manner would that be
useful and good for you in the medium to
long term it might make you feel you
know grudgingly satisfied you know in a
dark way temporarily but it's not a very
good long term strategy so I would say
you got to think it through
you know what how is it that you would
like to view the world how do you think
that would be best for you I mean as if
you were taking care of yourself like
you like you're someone who deserves to
be taken care of think about how you'd
like to have the world how you'd like to
view the world and one of the ways you
can do that too is to think about some
people that you admire and try to figure
out how they look at the world or even
ask them you know because maybe then you
can find out what it is about your
thought patterns that are driving you
down this sort of dark road so why are
you now Francoise Sade orange asks why
are you know hiding the amount you
receive from patreon I found it very
motivating to see the amounts skyrocket
and felt glad to be part of this as if
you were an artist I now feel more like
I'm buying a product and I find it less
appealing yeah well it's one of those
things where I'm kind of damned if I do
and damned if I don't you know and I
don't know what's correct I guess I
probably got tired of the sort of more
left-leaning let's say radical
left-leaning press people jumping up and
down on me every chance they got because
people were donating money for for
services that is particularly rent you
know that I render essentially for free
you know there must have been 10
articles in the last week following the
Lindsay Shepard incident pointing out
that I'm somehow being manipulative and
and
evil in a capitalist sort of way for
daring to allow people to donate money
to help support what I'm doing and it
gets kind of tiring and so I don't know
I just and I guess I also thought that
maybe there's a part of it that's like
well I wouldn't exactly call it bragging
but because it's not but that's about
good enough I mean it was an appeal to
privacy I suppose in part to I don't
know if it's the right thing I could do
a poll on Twitter and find out I guess I
did that for some other things this week
so anyways that's that's the answer to
that user and okay says I Love You Man
keep it up well that's a pretty good
question and I'm trying to keep it up
I'm actually feeling quite a bit better
I was actually happy today and it's been
so rare for the last while that I could
hardly even recognize what it felt like
so but I'm definitely feeling better I'm
getting some energy in the morning and
so I I'm really happy about that so
thanks anyways I appreciate it thoughts
on the radical left and their
superficial view belief and value on the
environment how is this influenced by
their own raw emotions inviting
questionable immoral and dangerous
actions despite good intentions well I
don't really buy the whole good
intentions thing I mean I think that
it's really hard to have good intentions
like John the question I just answered
you know John said looking at myself
honestly I'm deeply envious and
resentful of others happiness well if
you listen to the Lindsey Shepherd
recording at Wilfred Laurier University
and you listen to the professor's and
that the administrators I think that
it's a it's it's absurd to start with
the presupposition that they have good
intentions I don't think they have good
intentions at all so but you know we
could give the devil let's do and say
that there are people on the left end of
the spectrum like like there are on all
parts of the spectrum who are trying to
do good things but having good
intentions and figuring out how
do well in the world our good intentions
are only the beginning and people are
always influenced by raw emotions and
fuzzy thinking and it's hard to think
critically and it's hard to plan
strategically and it's hard to to
intervene in the world in a way that
doesn't cause trouble which is partly
why I recommend to people that they
start local you know you can't even
trust your own good intentions to some
degree because you have to test out what
you do when you have good intentions and
see if it actually produces the result
that's intended but I wouldn't make the
case to begin with that especially on
the radical end of the left I think it's
unbelievably motivated by resentment so
how does one save a marriage when it
seems that there is no longer attraction
both physically and intellectually
there are kids involved which is the
main reason for wanting to save the
marriage huh well alright I know a
couple of things about that I mean the
first thing I would say is that if you
haven't had any intimate interaction
with one another for quite a long period
of time that can put both people into a
stagnant state where desire starts to
slip away what what sex therapists
recommend under such conditions is to
well essentially start in some ways
start dating again so you could ask your
partner to go out to a movie or
something like that and you know maybe
when you come home you could you could
neck for a little while like teenagers
that's probably a word that no one uses
anymore but kind of pull back and you
gotta agree say not to engage in full
sexual activity for a while but to tease
each other and to play a bit even if
you're not attracted you have to act act
it out for a while and hopefully you can
get the motor running again the other
thing I would say is that you guys might
want to sit down and make a joint plan
it's like what because a marriage is
like a story that two people are acting
out simultaneous
and you have to have shared goals and
because you're both rowing the same boat
let's say and if you don't have a
destination in mind then well maybe your
rowing in circles or maybe you're just
standing still so I would say work hard
to put some romance back in the
relationship you know you could say to
each other look let's try this for six
months and just see how it goes
we'll have two dates a week for the
first month we won't have any sex but
we'll play around and then you know
we'll see how that goes and and but
we'll try it out for them for the whole
for the whole six months there are
reasons to save a marriage I mean it's
hard on kids divorce is really hard on
kids and it's hard on the adults
involved too so what I would say you
have to negotiate an agreement and you
you know you could try the future
authoring program both of you what I
would recommend for example is that you
each do the future authoring program
separately so that's at self authoring
com because then you both have a life
plan and then you could sit down and
read each other's future authoring plans
and see if you have some things in
common and then see if you can figure
out how to support each other with
regards to each of you obtaining what
you want
so Paul Moloney asks you edited out a
disagreement with Camille Paglia what
was it no no that's not the case
there was a piece added it out but it
wasn't because there was a disagreement
it was because there was some glitch in
the video or something like that
generally speaking and you know I can't
say this with absolute certainty but I
do and so does my crew do everything we
possibly can to leave the videos alone
except for getting rid of things that
would be of no interest to anyone that
are mistakes so there was no
disagreement are you interested in
coming to Australia yes I've been
invited a couple of times but it hasn't
worked out yet but my book will be
published in Australia I think sometime
in January as well and I imagine that
all be coming there at some point in
order to
talk about my book and so on Trey says
how can a person go through the future
authoring process of imagining a future
for yourself as though you or someone
you care about when you barely don't
care about yourself or even hate
yourself yeah well I would say that go
through the exercise anyways and and act
as like try to extend to yourself some
courtesy you know sometimes you have to
act something out before you can start
to believe it and so I would say sit
down and pretend that you're your friend
you know Trey the probability that
there's something so wrong with you that
you don't deserve any regard whatsoever
is zero you know so and I would say if
if you just can't get it together you
know maybe you're depressed and maybe
you need to go talk to someone because
you don't have to be depressed you talk
to a physician you know there are
treatments for depression if you happen
to be depressed and if you actually hate
yourself then it's a possibility that
that's what's going on I don't know how
old you are but you know there are
effective treatments for that sort of
thing you might want to find out if
there's actually something wrong
physically or or psycho physiologically
you know because you don't have to
trudge through life absolutely miserable
their antidepressants for example work
really well for some people not for
everyone but for some people so okay
were the Nazis left-wing that's a good
question it depends see the problem with
any question that says is a B is a
equivalent to B is that it depends on
how you define a and B right and I'm not
trying to weasel out of the question I'm
very very serious about that the Nazis
regarded themselves as National
Socialists you know so they weren't
free-market capitalist let's say so they
certainly weren't right-wingers in the
way that free-market capitalists are
right wingers even though they're
probably more sense
they differed from the International
Socialists which were the Marxists
because they were much more concerned
with national identity and racial
identity and to the degree that you
regard nationalism and racial identity
as primarily right-wing views then the
Nazis would have been right-wing so
let's say that they maybe they pulled
from the worst of both extreme something
like that but I do think it's reasonable
to note that their extreme nationalism
and ethnocentrism and racial identity
probably has more in common with the
radical right than it does with the
radical left which tends to be utopian
Universal so one of the things I thought
would be an interesting research project
would be to take like a hundred Nazi
policies and to turn them into a
questionnaire and ask people either how
much they agree with them after I
figured out whether they were left or
right wing to begin with or whether they
thought the policies were representative
of the left or the right because that
could be studied empirically and I don't
think anyone's done it but that would be
a very interesting that would be a very
interesting research project he's left
for helgesson a probably Matt Matt
massacred that name says who has a
higher IQ a really gifted mathematician
or a really gifted painter very
difficult to say but I would say that
gifted method because if they're both
gifted they both have high IQs you can
be certain of that it's very difficult
to do anything that's truly gifted say
above the average above the norm without
being without having a very high IQ and
in a creative realm I mean you hear
about these idiot savants who have like
one area of extreme expertise but
generally in those cases it's not so
much that they have one area of extreme
expertise it's that they have one area
of above-average expertise that really
contrasts with the rest of their
impairments but they rarely if ever make
it into the you know the very short list
of true geniuses mathematicians are kind
of an odd Bunch though because you they
peak really really early like if you're
going to be a mathematician and
gifted then you're going to show signs
of that when you're like 17 to 20
something like that whereas painters can
can be creative through it their entire
lifespan I would say probably on average
I would guess this is a guess that if
you took a hundred really gifted
mathematicians and a hundred really
gifted painters that the mathematicians
would have far higher nonverbal IQs but
the painters might have higher verbal
IQs so that also complicates things see
with IQ also you know there's there's
this factor called the G factor which is
the central element of intelligence and
it seems to be associated with such
things as head size and brain size
relative to body and neural conduction
speed and simple reaction time like
really basic physiological markers and
it's a pretty tight single factor say as
opposed to the personality dimensional
main where there's five quite clear
factors but I think it was Earl hunts
research indicated that as people get
smarter and smarter the variability
between the subsets of their
intelligence starts to increase so it's
sort of like there's a lot of ways to be
really smart but there's only one way to
be not very smart so that's another
little tidbit of information with
regards to IQ so
hello doctor I am a 23 year old male
with paranoid schizophrenia however I
feel like controlling 95% of it okay so
let's say I think you mean that you're
controlling 95% of it I desire to seek a
partner but I am afraid how to reveal it
any advice on how to approach it
Oh God Steven that's a really hard
question well look you're not under any
obligation when you first meet someone
to drown them in information about your
identity so I would say the devil's in
the details fundamentally if you have a
relationship with someone and it's
progressing and you're being honest my
suspicions are that it will come up of
its own accord you know that you'll be
able to tell in the situation when the
right way to introduce it is you know if
if you're asking me this because you've
been in a relationship for a long time
and you haven't revealed it then I don't
know what to tell you about that because
and because I wouldn't give someone
general advice about that you know if
sorry if I if I was speaking to a client
and I had some real detailed information
about their current situation I would
sit down and help them strategize about
that ask about the person you're telling
figure out how long you've gone out with
them figure out a way that it might be
revealed that you would be comfortable
with I suspect probably what you should
do is find someone you trust to talk
about it if you're already in a
relationship and if you're not then
assume that if going into the
relationship your basic goal is honesty
that you'll handle it appropriately when
the situation comes up so
how would you address accusations that
you are creating another ideological
group identity which is equal in its
capacity for destruction to postmodern
Neel Marxism well I would address it the
way I've been addressing it for the
whole last year which is that I'm not
trying to produce a group identity of
any sort I'm trying to get people to act
locally in the confines of their own
environment and to sort things out that
are under their direct control so it's
it's an elaboration of one of the ideas
I suppose that's in the New Testament
which is that you should take the log
out of your own eye before you worry
about the dust speck in your neighbors
eye which i think is a really good
general maxim and so there's nothing
about that that's associated with group
identity now people have tried to what
would you call it a tribute to me some
identity with the right or the alt right
or even the far right more recently even
Hitler which is what came up in at
wilfred laurier but i think the reason
for that is is twofold one is look if
you're imagine that there's a radical
left that's not very difficult to
imagine and then imagine that everyone
to the right of the radical left is are
all in opposition to the radical left so
then you have a group and the group is
all those in opposition to the radical
left and that will include people on the
radical right and so then when you look
at that entire group so let's say a
thousand people are 1500 people come in
here a talk that I give on free speech
that happened on November 11th first of
all if there's 1,500 people in a room
like 15 of them are gonna be completely
out of their mind
probably more like 30 but at least 15
and that's just base rate and so to
demonstrate that the group was somehow
pathological you'd have to show that the
base rate of pathology was higher in the
group than it would be in a randomly
selected group and I've seen no evidence
of that but also even if there are a
number of people say on the far right in
that group that doesn't indicate at all
that that's characteristic of the group
but it's very hard to distinguish that
because
what tends to happen is that a group is
defined by the most egregious behavior
of its most extreme members so anyways
the other way I did rest the accusation
is that and I have done this as well and
I think it's what really protected me
this whole year is that I have all these
YouTube videos online you know
600 hours of them and the message is
pretty stable that then more the newer
manifestation is you know a fairly
focused critique of the university which
i think is entirely justified but
everything around that is focused on the
individual and the role of the
individual and the responsibility of the
individual and so I don't believe that
that is an ideological group identity so
that's how I would address it so alright
let's see what else we've got here
what is the evolutionary reason for
having consciousness I think that was
Toby who asked that God Only Knows
that's been a problem that people have
been hammering on for a long time I mean
that's the so-called zombie problem that
David Chalmers has described which is
something like how do you know that
other people aren't exactly like you
except acting in a completely determined
manner and devoid of consciousness I
don't know what the evolutionary reason
is for consciousness I mean I can
speculate like what consciousness seems
to be at least in part is a mechanism of
repair so a lot of the things that you
do are unconscious you know like when
you're driving if you're an expert
driver you're you're using your eyes to
watch the road and your eyes are moving
your hands and your arms but you're not
really thinking about what you're doing
you're not attending to it consciously
because you've built circuitry already
specialized circuitry that handles all
those tasks now what happens when you're
driving let's say that you make a
mistake well then what happens is you
consciously attend to the mistake and
you attempt to revise the part of the
automatic structure that produced the
error so imagine this imagine you're
playing the piano and you're playing a
very complicated sequence and you
stumble over part of it so you're
zooming along and you stumble over part
of it and then you attend to that you go
back and you slow down and you move your
fingers slowly and you try to reprogram
those little automatic units that have
handled that part of it you repair them
and and reprogram them and you get
faster and faster out it as they
automatize and then you go so
consciousness seems to be something that
watches what you do automatically checks
for errors and then repairs it and so
that's its function now you might ask
why a repair mechanism like that would
have to be associated with awareness and
answer that is not only do I not know I
don't think anyone knows if I was
speculating and which I've done I think
consciousness actually plays an intake
role in being itself because I'm not
convinced that there would be any being
of any recognizable sort without a
conscious observer so I think
consciousness is actually like a center
point of the cosmos in some sense and I
think it's because of ideas like that
that the grand archetypal idea of the
soul has emerged and I think it's
correct so but how to precisely
integrate that with evolutionary theory
apart from the description that already
provided I just don't I just don't know
so let's see what else have we got here
would you consider a more official
consultancy role with Andrew sheers
conservative party it's very difficult
to say what I would consider it isn't
obvious to me that Andrew Shearer would
particularly like to have me as an
official consultant I'm kind of what
might you describe controversial yes
that's the word right now and so you
know it's funny though because I was
making this new video today which I
alluded to earlier using good old what's
this character here Hitler the Hitler
the spokes frog and I I went back and
looked at my comments on Bill c16 last
year which which were the comments that
originally got me in hot water and had
me accused of all the things I've been
accused of transphobia bigotry racism
what else Oh
fascism being on the far-right and then
finally and to top it all off Hitler
himself and one of the things that I
realized was that that I was really calm
during that video you couldn't have
really
I couldn't have offered a more
mild-mannered criticism of Bill c16 and
it's pretty funny because you know this
scandal that engulfed wilfred laurier
this week is the worst scandal that I
remember involving a university in in in
my memory going back to the 1970s and
happened at Laurie it was exactly what I
predicted would happen except it was
actually worse because they did accuse
Lindsay of breaking the law bill c16
specifically and of contravening the
Ontario Human Rights Code which I you
know for all I know she might have done
so we're at this situation where a TA
showing a video of someone discussing
pronouns in Canada can now be termed a
hate crime and illegal provincially and
federally and like all the usual
suspects have come out of their caves
let's say like Brenda Cosman the lawyer
I debated last year and said well it's a
real stretch to assume that what Lynn's
a shepherd did was was you know
sufficiently reprehensible to actually
constitute a violation of the Ontario
Human Rights Commission guidelines
policies it's a stretch so I guess we're
supposed to feel good about that but I'm
probably a little bit too hot right now
to serve in any official consultant role
that doesn't mean that I wouldn't be
happy to speak to you know political
figures who might be interested in
speaking with me because you know I
generally speak to people who asked me
to speak to them so as reprehensible as
that might be recently moved up and was
promoted and not liking it because I
have to adjust massively is there a
difference between liking your job and
the lack of discipline to perform a
change are there are they connected yeah
well they're definitely connected it's a
tough one the first thing I would say is
that if it was a real radical change you
know it takes people unless they're very
young it takes people about a year to
adjust to a really radical change like
to move to a new city to to adjust to
being married that can take longer than
a year to adjust to having a new baby to
to getting over a relatively serious
loss like a death in the family a year
you know and so
the first thing you might ask yourself
is are there things that are good about
the promotion
the second is do you have the capacity
to do the job or to learn how to do it
you could talk to someone about that and
then the third thing is have you given
yourself enough time to adjust because
one of the things I often recommend to
people when they've made a radical
change like going leaving home and going
to university is don't pay any attention
to how you feel for a year because
everything is so much up in the air that
you can't really trust your own judgment
so you have to give yourself time to
adapt and you can't expect that that's
going to happen overnight it's certainly
not and to put that expectation on
yourself increases the probability that
you're going to feel bad about it so
let's see
atomic Carlos says my IQ is north of
1:30 yet I question my own intelligence
all the time I feel big cognitive
dissonance between what people expect of
me and what I consider myself capable to
do well you know Carlos what I would
recommend there is that if if you
haven't done it just go do the
personality test that understand myself
calm because what you're describing
sounds very much like high levels of
negative emotionality or neuroticism and
you might want to find out if that's the
case because if you're much higher than
average in neuroticism then you're going
to be questioning yourself all the time
and you might want to figure out if
that's actually a trait and if it is a
trait well then that gives you an
explanation of it and then you might
also note that your levels of negative
emotion are not well matched to your
likely skill now that doesn't
necessarily help you learn to cope with
it but sometimes identifying the reason
is usefull and there's another
possibility - is that your mood is
dysregulated and that you're depressed
so that's another thing to consider if
you if you do find that you have high
levels of neuroticism but you're not
depressed then one of the things you
might do is write down all the reasons
like really think them out you know I
mean really get serious about this write
down all the reasons why you might give
yourself more credit for intelligence
than you have and part about could be
like a really deep reconsideration of
successes you've had in the past with
complex intellectual issues because
imagine that you're serving as your own
defense attorney against a very critical
part of your mind that can help a lot
that can help
Marlene says my little girl loves
you
well that's that's good I guess you
could say hi to her for me I hope that
she has a great little life so give her
a pat on the head and tell her that I
think that little kids are the greatest
thing on earth so
that cognizant of the modern art scene
so it isn't easy to figure out how to
how to answer that question so I haven't
been thinking also about art for quite a
long time because I've been so engaged
in all this political and philosophical
material so but music as far as music
goes I really like the last recordings
of Johnny Cash who else springs to mind
I like a very large variety of a lot of
different genres of music as well so
I'll have to leave it at that I think
Richard Boyle says hi dr. Peterson how
does this score of 91 for compassion and
1 for politeness equals a score of 35
for agreeableness yeah well it's because
91 and 1 aren't ordinary numbers they're
percentiles and you can't just average
percentiles it doesn't work that way
what it says is that let's see I don't
know if I can generate at just a
description on the fly because I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm particularly
mathematically gifted although I know
that the answer I just gave you is
correct let's see there's a 1 in there's
a 1 in 10 chance that a person would be
that compassionate and a 1 and a hundred
percent chance that a person would be
that come that that nope I can't
generate it on the fly but that's the
answer so if you want to point to the
proper literature you'd look up how to
transform percentiles into z-scores
they're called z-scores then you can if
you oh that's how it works you convert
the percentiles into z-scores you some
the z-scores and then you re convert
them into percentiles and so if you take
the z-score for naught for compassion 91
and the z-score for politeness 1 add
them divide them into Andry convert them
to a percentile you'll get 35 I know
it's weird but that's that's how it
that's how it is that's how it's done so
let's see the opioid crisis this is army
jato or hate oh the opioid crisis in my
community in the Midwest of America
greatly bothers me I have been thinking
about becoming a police officer the
culture hasn't been very favorable
towards cops lately
maybe maybe majoring in law and grad
school instead advice please Thanks
well if you're if you're gonna be a
police officer you should be very
emotionally stable so low in neuroticism
and very high in conscientiousness if
you're gonna be a lawyer you better be
very bright first you you need to be
extremely bright verbally in particular
you need to be extremely conscientious
you need to be emotionally stable and
you need to be fairly disagreeable
that's that's what characterizes lawyers
if you're high in openness in creativity
let's say I would say neither cop nor
law is a good occupation for you so I
wouldn't worry about the culture not
being too favorable towards cops that's
I don't think it's really any worse than
it was
it's probably not as bad as it was in
the sixties and I don't think that it'll
necessarily continue I don't think you
should let that stop you because you
know the police have their own
Brotherhood and you'd find your
community within that you what I would
say you should think more about what you
want then how other people view the
occupation I know that's relevant but
you should think about what you want and
think of see if you can figure out if
the life of a policeman would actually
interest you or the life of a lawyer
like lots of people go into law and
don't like it you have to be
argumentative you have to really be
literate because there's so much reading
and writing you have to be able to write
you have to be able to lay out clear
arguments you have to be really orderly
and detail-oriented because there's so
many things to keep track of so you got
to make sure you got the right
temperament for that so you can try the
Big Five personality scale to understand
myself like I said the good lawyers are
high in conscientiousness low in
neuroticism pretty disagreeable and then
extraversion helps to some degree
because it makes you better in the court
and it also makes you better at
generating sales leads which you know
growing your business which is super
important if you're a lawyer like lots
of people are competent lawyers but only
a small set of competent lawyers are
also good at generating new business and
that makes you extremely valuable so if
you've got a Salesman aspect to you as
well as those other traits which makes
you a pretty rare person then you know
you could be a bang-up lawyer so linked
with a lightsaber says hey man as a
Canadian I just wanted to say thanks
Canada is short on Heroes these days and
I'm glad to see you fill that role
thanks again but hey well thanks a lot
man I don't really think of myself as a
hero I think of myself as someone who's
on a relatively small raft perched on a
relatively large wave paddling like a
mad dog and trying not to be submerged
so and so far well I haven't drowned yet
so you know
hooray for that so hey guys I'm gonna
read you a little bit of my book if you
don't mind somewhere near the end of
this it's let's see I'll probably go for
about two hours so we got about another
hours so I figured I'd read something to
you for about 15 minutes uh if you're
interested in that why don't you just
say so in the comments section that
would be good then I could see what
people think of that idea let's see here
sorry it's taken me just a little while
to good someone says well I'll tell all
ah
go for that let's see
hi Jordan what are feelings and why do
we have them well here's a way of
thinking about it so look let's say you
were walking down a pathway I actually
saw this happen one day so I'll tell you
this story so I was walking along the
cliffs near I think it was San Diego
where la I don't remember
I think it's probably I think it was it
I think it was San Diego anyways I was
walking along there with some friends
and and a brother of a friend of mine
who was quite a tall guy is about six
foot five something like that and he was
walking along the path on the edge of
the cliff kind of sandy and with with
scrub pine around overlooking the
Pacific Ocean and it was March I think
so was warm but not too warm we were
walking along and all of a sudden his
little girl who I think was like four or
five I saw she was walking in front of
him and in front of me and I guess we
were going round a little bit of a
corner and all of a sudden she jumped
right up on his shoulders which I'd
never seen a child do that it was like
watching you know if you if a cat sleep
in you and you and you go at it it'll
like jump up and puff out its hair and
can jump straight up well that's what
this kid did and there was a rattlesnake
out the side of the of the path now it
was cold which was probably good but you
know there's a guy named uh-oh
oh I carry he wrote a great book on fear
it'll come to me it'll come to me it's a
book that I should have on my book list
actually and he showed that there are
circuits in your brain there reflex
circuits so this had been demonstrated
to some degree much earlier that map so
imagine that a snake is a pattern and
then imagine that there's a pattern on
your retina that constitutes the snake
and then imagine that that can be
transformed into another pattern which
is a muscular output pattern and that
muscular output pattern is to jump you
in the air so your eyes make your your
make your muscles move in a particular
way in and that happens before you see
the snake and before you're afraid and
the reason for that is that so it's
there are not many neural connections
between snake detection and leaping in
the air and that's because if you waited
to feel fear and waited to see the snake
that would take between a quarter and
half a second something like that and
the snake would have already bitten you
so unless you had those really short
neural pathways that have been conserved
in the evolutionary process since
the beginning of time anything super
fast and simple would be able to kill
you
so now so let's say that you do
encounter something unexpected well
first you have these bodily reflexes
that are really fast and then the next
thing that happens generally speaking is
that you feel an emotion like maybe
you're frozen so if you hear a real
growl behind you you'll freeze and then
you'll feel fear and that'll keep you
frozen and so the the fear is a an
indication of that physiological state
and then only after that will you start
to think and strategize and so you need
reactions at multiple levels of temporal
resolution in order to keep you safe in
the world and the fast reactions are
muscular and reflexive and then the next
ones generally speaking or something
like emotions and they're low resolution
but quick you know like if you're afraid
it means there's something that may be
dangerous it's vague it's not till you
explore it that you know exactly what
the danger is but the fear is a good
enough initial category so you could
think about feelings as instinctual
categories things to love things to eat
things to run away from things to run
towards they're low resolution
categories and that's how animals
categorize the world they use emotion
and motivation to categorize the world
so we have them to keep ourselves
properly oriented in the world and to
react quickly and so that we can stay
alive so okay let's see here what else
have we got recently I took a job
working at a camp with at risk boys
where well there I will live and work as
a counselor in a house with the kids
any advice for working with young people
with behavioral issues yeah it depends
what the behavioral issues are so I
don't know what out risk means but so I
can't be too specific but what I can
tell you is that almost nothing beats
listening you know like take a kid for a
walk
let him talk like listen to them ask him
questions you know because most
disturbed people and maybe even most
people
don't actually have anyone they can talk
to and they need to talk first of all to
find out that someone actually cares
enough to listen so it's sort of like a
validation of the fact that they exist
and second so that they can sort out
their own thoughts so as a beginning
counselor the best thing you can do is
listen you don't want to give advice
really you know because what you want
you can ask questions that might lead
someone in an advisable direction but
the problem with giving advice is that
people are much more likely to remember
something and to implement it if they've
thought it up in their own words I think
that actually produces a kind of
neurological transformation the idea has
to be engendered from within it's one of
the prime dicta of of psychoanalytic
theory for example and I think it's a
really good one so yeah when and with
regards so Brendon crystal says trippy
snakes and retinas yeah like it's really
specific so this woman named no I
probably can't remember her name II any
either she she wrote a book about trees
and serpents she's a UCLA professor the
fruit the tree and the serpent I think
it's called she showed quite clearly
that not only do our retinas say
directly detect snakes but they do a
better job in the bottom half of the
retina and that we're really good at
detecting the camouflage patterns that
are characteristic of snakes - snakes
have these like diamond patterns which
are very very rare and we have
specialized circuitry for detecting
those and there was recent research
conducted that showed that children 6
months old who had never been exposed to
anything even resembling a snake had an
automatic response to snakes and so it
actually seems to be innate not just not
just easily learned so that's really
quite interesting so
okay let's go back to the pigeonhole
thing here how do you clean your room
when your spouse doesn't share that goal
huh
well that's another one of those
questions that's really hard to answer
because I don't have the details you
know how do you clean your room
what goals does your spouse have that's
the first thing I mean do is there some
commonality I mean it might be maybe
you're a spouse is much more disorderly
than you or less conscientious or
irritated at you for all sorts of
reasons you know the first thing you
could do is try to lead by example and
see how that works but you may have to
argue and fight it out you know break it
down into subtasks and and see if you
can distribute the the tasks and and
negotiate you have to negotiate and
without further information I can't say
much more than that you know you can say
why you're doing it what you think the
goal were and goal was and that you'd
like some help and maybe there's
something you could offer in return
if you can't negotiate it all with your
spouse then you have a much broader
problem then how do you clean your room
when your spouse doesn't share that goal
cuz the real problem would be how do you
learn to negotiate with your spouse I
could talk about that a little bit I
mean the first thing that you have to do
if you want to negotiate with someone is
be able to say no the second thing is to
have something to offer the third thing
is to find out what they want and to
know what you want you know because
often people especially with people that
love them they say well if you really
knew if you really loved me then you'd
know what I want it's like no that's
just wrong the person that you are in
love with or that living with isn't any
smarter than you and so you pretty much
always have to tell people straight out
what you want and then you have to let
them be really stupid about giving it to
you for quite a while you know so
sometimes I've recommended to my clients
that they take their wife or husband out
on a date and of course they're all
skeptical about that and cynical about
it and then they go on a date and they
have a terrible time and they come back
and say I told you that was a stupid
idea and I tell them a lot that's it
then a you're not gonna do
anything romantic with your spouse for
the next 40 years that's your plan
that's the plan is it it's like you
might have to go out to a movie after
you have it been good to each other for
like five years you might have to go out
to a movie ten times movie and dinners
say before it starts to become fun again
it's like it's hard to do that sort of
thing right you know people think those
things are easy and they're not so
anyways you have to you have to learn to
negotiate with your spouse and that's a
very difficult thing to do so figuring
out what you want is a good way to start
so okay what advice would you give the
parent of an only child well make sure
that the child your child has lots of
time for free play with other kids and
by free play I mean play with no
electronic gadgets not sitting in front
of the TV the kids have to be able to
learn how to amuse themselves and and to
especially to engage in pretend play say
if they're between three and probably 11
damn near that time with other kids is
extremely important and kids don't get
enough time for free play so that's what
I would say is get them around other
kids as much as you can and not under
situations where the parents are going
to just sit them in front of the TV or
something like that to amuse them so
they don't make too much noise
it's not like there's anything wrong
with seeing them and letting them watch
a movie but there's nothing wrong with
the movie but there is something wrong
with not giving the kids enough time to
engage in spontaneous play it's a
catastrophe
so how is the grandpa going I think it's
going pretty well
I it's quite a lot of fun to have a
little baby around again I mean I think
like most men I'm somewhat nonplussed
let's say by infants it's easier for me
to deal with kids after they're about
once they get mobile a once I can sort
of throw them around a bit
or then I know what to do with them once
I can play with them but it's really fun
to watch my daughter be a mother she's
really good at it and it's good to have
another young thing in the family and
you know because babies are very they're
kind of like fire you you can't help but
watch them and it's great it's great and
she seems healthy and you know what
she's cute as can be of course babies
are sneaky that way but it's working so
yeah I think it's really going well so I
constantly cannot verbalize my thoughts
written and vocal regardless of topic
and my level of knowledge tips for
verbalizing thoughts to get them into
writing and therefore speech well what I
would say Lauren is do this like read
something put a decide try to summarize
it in writing and talk while you're
doing it and then write down what you
say and don't edit while you're doing
that see one of the problems that people
have when they're trying to write is
they try to write a good sentence they
not only try to write a sentence but
they try to write a good sense and you
can't do that you have to write a
sentence that's hard enough and then you
have to edit it so allow yourself to
write badly I'm dead serious about this
like write a bad bad bad first draft and
then edit it if you get rid of 70% of it
so what that's exactly what should
happen so like if you want to write a
thousand word essay you should start by
writing a really bad two thousand word
essay and then you should get rid of the
worst 50% you can do that iteratively
I have a document online it's it's if
you go to my website under courses
there's psychology for 30 is the course
I should make this more public but under
cycle psychology for 30 there's a
template for writing and if you went
looked at that template it tells you it
answers your question I I produced this
little guidebook for for writing that
will help and if you write enough you'll
learn to speak the other thing I would
say too is that
it might be anxiety that's doing you
might think about joining a club like
Toastmasters or maybe if you're a
university student to public speaking
something where you'd get in front of
people and then when you're in front of
people don't talk to the group talk to
the individuals within the group and let
yourself be bad at it you'll get better
as you practice what is your plan if
YouTube deletes your account all right
cause as much trouble as I possibly
could and I don't think they will I do
have it
I do have most of my videos on Vimeo I
think I haven't had I did try to do that
I set up an automated service to
duplicate them I've never checked to see
if it work which is probably stupid but
I've been so overwhelmed with with this
with with this surreal position that I
found myself in that I haven't been able
to be sufficiently diligent so how to be
less afraid of death hmm I have a better
suggestion you should be more afraid of
not living properly I don't know if you
can be less afraid of death exactly but
I think that here's a hypothesis and
this is a Socratic hypothesis I write
about this in my book too by the way
maybe if you live your life thoroughly
thoroughly right you take use of the
Advanta just make use of the advantages
that are put in front of you make use of
your talents say yes to things tell the
truth like stand up and get out it
assuming that you can do that you know
because some people are very ill and and
hurt and but assuming you can do that I
think the only way to combat fear of
death is to live fully and I think that
that might actually work I kind of
wonder I've talked about this with my
father - who's getting pretty old you
know I've asked him if for example if he
could be transformed back into an 18
year old knowing what he knows now would
he do it and he was ambivalent about
that you know he didn't say no but he
didn't say yes and we talked about
this idea that if you lived your life
fully you know maybe that would be good
enough because you know I loved having
kids but I don't feel that I would have
kids again you know because in some
sense I've already done that and so
maybe there's a set number of adventures
that you have to go on in your life
let's say you have to be married you
have to have kids you have to have a
career you have to have friends you have
to have something useful to do with your
time outside of work all those are all
things that are covered in the future
authoring program by the way maybe if
you do all those it's like that's good
enough you've had your life and and
that's enough I mean I don't know ten
years ago I thought you know if I could
extend my life radically then I would
and I'm not so sure about that now then
I'm I'm 55 you know I'm getting older I
kind of have a suspicion that you might
come to an end you know that's what it
looks like I mean I don't want that to
be soon but maybe you exhaust yourself
in your life you know maybe you can so
that there's nothing left of you really
it's a good goal anyways so okay let's
find out let's go back to this other
doctor Peterson I have an interview for
medicine coming up very soon it's
structured in the MMI format and it's
intensely competitive any tips on how to
stand out from the rest well the only
thing I could say is that two things one
is really pay attention to the
interviewers right super attention like
don't glare at them like you're
aggressively paranoid but like make sure
you're focused on them and then the
other thing I would say is say what you
really think
like tell the truth it'll make you first
of all if you tell the truth and it
doesn't work then you know maybe that's
not the school for you that's something
to really think about
and if it doesn't work anywhere and you
tell the truth maybe medicine isn't for
you and I know that might be a terrible
shock but let's assume that you are
genuinely properly motivated to study
medicine then tell them what you think
you know so many people when they go
into an interview try and they do this
when they write essays to is try to tell
the interviewers what you think they
want to hear but you can bloody well be
sure that virtually everybody who's
being interviewed is gonna do that and I
don't think that's very advisable
because if you don't manifest yourself
the way you are then there's no way that
the path that's proper for you can
reveal itself I know that sounds sort of
mystical but I don't know how to put it
any better the best way to stand out in
an interview always assuming you're
competent and that you've done the
preparation you know and that you're not
living a lie is to actually say what you
think and hopefully what will happen is
that there will be other people on the
panel that's that's that are looking at
you who are of the same type and that
would characterize a good position for
you a good place to be if there are
people like that and they'll note what
you're doing and that will that would
then they'll think you know that person
you know they're there they'd be good
they're straightforward they're honest
they're they're tough they're they can
say what they think and if there aren't
people like that on the panel then I
would say you probably don't want to go
there anyways so that's what I would
that's what I would do the true to
yourself you know but that also assumes
that you've done your homework and that
you're prepared and all of that because
if you're a useless jackass and you're
yourself well obviously that is going to
work so good luck good luck with your
interview
but I always think that like the other
thing too is don't treat the
interviewers as enemies you know if
that's hard because if you're kind of
petrified about the potential outcome
and you feel intense judgement then
you're likely to go in there kind of
afraid and nervous and and and maybe
even resentful it's like you've already
done enough so that you're going to get
interviewed so
in some sense the interviewers are
hoping that you'll be great
already you know there might be the odd
cynic in there who's trying to figure
out a reason to give you an X and check
you off the list but most of the people
sitting there if they have a clue are
going to be looking for good candidates
and they're gonna assume that you're
you've hit threshold and so it's not
like they're not on your side and so
that's a good thing to keep in mind too
you're not going in there to face a
panel of enemies you're going in there
to face a panel of the sort of people
that you're likely to be in ten years so
that's another thing that's really
useful to keep in mind with interviews
in general I would say so okay
many of my friends sing the wonders of
diversity I try to tell them diversity
isn't a moral good but I end up looking
like some terrible racist why isn't
diversity a moral good well diversity is
a moral good but you can't diversity by
race doesn't produce diversity that's
that's called racism that idea or
diversity of gender doesn't produce
diversity unless that's how you define
diversity look let's say that you get
diversity partly as a consequence of
personality which is a good way of
looking at it there is more diversity
within groups of people than between so
like men and women differ to some degree
in their personalities but there's far
more difference between men within the
male group and women within the male
group than there is between the average
or typical male and female so it's a
stupid wait let's assume that what you
want the organization is pursuing a
complex goal and you want a variety of
skills that would be suited to that goal
then you want there to be enough
diversity of ability within the group so
that the goal can be achieved in a
efficient and and and inexpensive manner
right because what do you want
unofficial tanned expensive obviously
not so there's a presumption that you
get diversity by using identity politics
categories but there's absolutely no
evidence for that whatsoever so
that's why diversity defined by race or
ethnicity or gender is not only not a
moral good it's actually a moral evil
because it dispenses with the whole idea
of the individual dispenses with the
idea of competence it just replaces it
with the assumption that if you randomly
select from the population because
that's how you would get real equity you
randomly select from the population that
that gives you the best qualified group
of people well that's just that's you
wouldn't do that to select the Plumber
it's it's the stupidest possible way of
selecting for anything randomly you know
there's no difference between selecting
randomly and selecting accidentally so
it's moral diversity defined properly is
a moral good diversity based on identity
politics categories is a positive evil
you know true to our prime ministers
great example of that
so back I think it was in 2015 he
announced that half of his cabinet was
going to be women because it was 2015 or
some like muddle-headed virtue Signori
signaling excuse for not thinking I
think only 20% or 25% of the elected MPs
were female so the proper balance on
average would it be 25 percent female 75
percent male what he should have done
was figured out who what qualities would
make for a confident cabinet minister
because it's actually quite important to
have competent cabinet ministers and
then selected from among his people for
nothing other than competence but he
could virtue signal and then he set up
the most important board let's say of
the entire country on a quasi random
basis
Jesus how pathetic he should have been
pilloried by Canadians for that but
we're so clued out and and also in the
situation that you described it's like
if I say well 50% of Trudeau's cabinet
shouldn't have been women it's like oh
you're a misogynist it's like no only
25% of the elected officials were women
now you might say well it would be
better if 50% of them were elected it's
like maybe it would be better but it
didn't happen
so you can't you can't fix it at the
top-end it was appalling
so it's a hard argument to make you know
because you need to know that there's
more difference within groups than
between them in order to be able to come
up with a credible argument you know and
then so yeah yeah how does one
distinguish a statement coming from
oneself rather than from ideology hey I
got a good hint about that if you're
saying something that almost anyone else
could say then it's likely to be either
cliched or ideological where is if
you're speaking from yourself then in
some sense you're the only person who
could be saying that and so what that
means in some sense is that you've taken
ideas philosophical even ideological and
you've made them personal so that you're
speaking from a position that only you
can speak from and then then you have
something original to offer in
Solzhenitsyn school like archipelago he
talked about like radical communists who
were thrown into the gulag and they used
to play comrade with them it was a game
and what they would do is bait them into
making continual propagandistic
communist statements was an attempt to
try to educate them out of their
possession but it's a good see if you
can predict what someone is going to say
on the basis of their set of beliefs
then they're not speaking the ideology
is speaking and if the ideology is
speaking you don't even have to listen
to them you could just read about the
ideology and make up your own mind now
so that's that's sort of the what would
you call it that's the objective view of
this the subjective view is that
statements come from yourself that come
from yourself I think first of all
frightened you to some degree because
you actually open yourself up to the
world by saying something genuine but
they also make you stronger they make
you feel stronger but because I think
you're confronting your vulnerability
properly you know because if I tell you
something that I really don't believe
and you criticize it's like who cares
because I don't really believe it
anyways so maybe I have an ideology
that's like a mask or a persona which is
generally the case
sona's a union concept that means masks
and it's often the thing that people
confuse with the real identity well if I
have a persona and someone criticizes it
it's like well you haven't gone to the
real me but if I say something that I
really believe deeply believe and then
it gets criticized like I've already put
myself on the line and so people don't
do that it's kind of frightening but
it's it's still the way to genuine
strength because you need and also not
just strength but also value you need to
manifest yourself in the world because
you're a unique thing and people might
need what's unique about you everybody
else might really need that I believe
that you know because each person has
something that's unique to them to bring
into being and if they hide that they
hide their light under a bushel that
everyone is poorer for it and you do
that in part as Solzhenitsyn says by
turning in you're turning over your
god-given soul to human dogma it's a
very bad idea very bad idea so ok let's
see what else we've got here what time
is it to 21
someone said daddy read for us yeah no
problem man I'm gonna do it
David Maxwell I scored the zeroth
percentile for conscientiousness in the
84th for neuroticism how do i improve
these scores well okay so the first
thing David you might want to think
about is like if all of your scores were
low then there's some possibility that
you're being too hard on yourself and
what I would recommend then is get a
couple of friends to fill out the
questionnaire for for you to describe
you and then see if first of all if
there's any agreement see if they've
they are easier on you than you are
yourself so but let's assume that you
are rather low in conscientiousness the
next question would be well how young
are you because younger people tend to
be lower in conscientiousness so if
you're like 16 well that's low but it's
not catastrophic if you're like 40 and
you're not depressed then 0th is you
know that's low anyways if you are that
low in conscientiousness one of the
things I would recommend is a make a
plan and B learn how to use a schedule a
calendar and do it badly to begin with
like an electronic calendar like Google
Calendar that's the best thing I know of
to improve conscientiousness make a plan
so that you've got something to aim at
and use a scheduler and maybe you have
to you know talk to someone to help keep
you on track now the other question
would be do you have other personality
traits that are really high like
openness because if you're really high
and openness then it might be that
you're more inclined towards being
motivated by spontaneous interest and in
the artistic direction and if you're
really high an extraversion then you're
going to be motivated by being around
people you know so it also may be that
in order to be conscientious about
something you have to pick a domain that
you're suited to like socializing or
artistic endeavor and try to work on
being conscientious in those domains so
that's it so
James Montgomery says how can you be
confident and courageous if your father
was emotionally absent and narcissistic
I'm 21 and very creative my mother is a
people pleaser who isn't confident in
herself and uses me as emotional support
help
well look you're confident about some
things you said you were very creative
so you're confident enough to say that
and you know you I don't see the problem
with questions like this I'm not
criticizing your question by the way is
that you're linking your lack of
confidence and courage to the absence of
your father and his narcissism and also
associating it with your mother being a
people pleaser so and you know there may
be something to that
it could be James that you could could
stand to talk to somebody you know for a
while on a regular basis and see if they
can help you sort this out you obviously
seem to think that this is a problem
with you moving forward in your life if
you don't want to talk to someone about
it then I would say the other thing you
need a plan I know I always refer to
that but it's the case you need a plan
and then you need to break the plan down
into this into small steps that are
somewhat challenging that you have a
high probability of nonetheless
obtaining and then I would say by
observing yourself move forward properly
that your confidence will increase
you're only 21 you know so you know at
that old but that's the best I can do
without having more information about
the specifics of your situation
can't increase your IQ in any
significant way
eat healthy do the right thing best
potential well one of the things you can
do if not to increase it is at least to
maintain it is that because your IQ
tends to decline as you age it's quite
depressing if you read the relevant
literature your crystallized IQ which is
an indication of your accumulated
knowledge doesn't decline and sometimes
it even increases you know unless you
get dementia or something like that but
your fluid IQ which is more like the
programmer of the brain declines a lot
the best way to deal with that is to
exercise both aerobic and weight lifting
can really stave off cognitive decline
and that's because your brain is a very
cut it's very demanding it has a very
demanding set of cardiovascular
requirements and so if your
cardiovascular system is in good shape
then your brain is healthier and since
at least in principle your IQ depends on
your brain then having a healthy brain
is really a good idea so
gerri Newton says I often don't do very
well don't very well and doubt my
ability to stand up for myself in
discussions and aggressive situations
how do I know when I've incorporated my
shadow I guess I would say Jerry that
practice makes perfect you know one
thing you could do is start keeping
track of situations like that you know
where you you walk away thinking that
you should have said something and so
then I would say write down the
situation and then think through and
write down what you think you should
have done and that because that's gonna
help you be sharper on the draw and more
ready when and then so so write down the
situation write down what you think you
should have done then sit and imagine
the situation as vividly as you can
right get the pictures in your head and
imagine yourself doing that and and try
to get the psychophysiological responses
up as well so that you make it as
realistic as possible and that will
actually help you practice so Edna FOA
who's a very good clinical psychologist
has demonstrated quite clearly that when
treating post-traumatic stress disorder
for example if you get people to sit and
imagine being back in the stressful
situation they have to do that
voluntarily and after at least 18 months
after the trauma that she did
psychophysiological recording of heart
rate and skin conductance and that kind
of thing she showed that the people who
showed the highest levels of stress
reactivity to the reimagining were the
ones who got better fastest and stayed
better longest so you have a situation
that you know you haven't mastered
define the situation repeatedly define
your proper action repeatedly practice
implementing that in your imagination
and then start to do that in your real
life and that'll that'll LA see if you
write down what you should have said
you'll find out what you really want and
what you really think
and that's that'll be your shadow
talking it that's the best way to think
about it is that the part of your brain
that wishes it would have done something
different
is the shadow associated with the
aggression whose integration would
strengthen your character that's that's
a very good way of of thinking about it
so Matt says oh this isn't okay Oh Matt
says I need to ask you something can you
please release your new book as an audio
book as well in your own voice yes I'm
doing that I'm starting to record it on
Monday
I'm kind of surprised that people want
me to record it in my own voice which is
kind of scratchy at the moment
but I'm looking forward to it I've been
practicing reading it with my wife puts
her to sleep at night hopefully that's
not because of the book she does get
quite tired at night so let's see here
would you ever consider having a dialog
with legitimate Muslim scholar yes
absolutely and I know a number of them
and I'm hoping that I'll get to that
it's a big thing to take on you know and
I'm trying to deal with this biblical
lecture series and with well all the
other things that I'm involved in
including starting to lay the groundwork
for this online university which is
which and I've started looking for an
office where a team could work on that
and we've sketched out some of the ideas
we're gonna use competitive writing
exercises to help teach people to write
which I think would really be fun so one
idea is so imagine and remember this is
just the outline of idea imagine we
present you with a paragraph that
someone else wrote and then you have the
opportunity to do a better job of
writing it and then people get the
opportunity to vote on whose is better
you can see that the paragraphs could
compete and that you could get academic
points based on the quality of your
writing anyways that's all to say
especially also with this book coming
out is that I'm going to be very
occupied and I want to start a dialogue
with legitimate Muslim scholars because
I would also like to learn more about
Islam so hopefully that'll happen in the
in that relatively
your future so
Jake says I've been incredibly inspired
by you love what you do and would like
to enlighten people in a similar manner
be careful what you wish for
it is is it appropriate to aim to have
as much as an impact as you or more so I
think it's the ideas formulated wrong in
some sense I think I mean it's good to
have people that you admire let's say
who can serve as models and I'm not
claiming that I'm necessarily in that
category but it's good to have people
like that but what you want to figure
out to do to do to do is how to manifest
the ideal within the confines of your
own life right because you're a
particular sort of person and so the way
that you're going to live your life best
it's very unlikely that it would be
associated in any important way with the
way that I've chosen to live my life be
unless we have very similar temperaments
which is possible but you know
relatively unlikely because the odds
against that are it's you know
extraordinarily high the odds of any two
people having the same temperament are
very are very high so what you can do is
aim to to orient yourself towards a high
good that you can conceive up to
discipline yourself to tell the truth
and all of that and then what I would
say is that as your life unfolds you'll
have the amount of influence that you
should have whatever that happens to be
you know some people live pretty local
lives like my life for example is much
more public than my wife's life but that
doesn't mean that her contribution is
somehow lesser I mean she's been
unbelievably good with her kids my
daughter was very ill and my wife was
extraordinarily good with her and was a
great mother and it's been a tremendous
help to me as a very honest person and a
wise person and you know that all has an
impact it's just not as obvious because
well the kids really loved her and now
she's got grandkids and god only knows
what the consequence of that is going to
be across successive generations and you
know she isn't interested in the public
life
journalists have asked interviewer like
quite recently about what the last
year's been like and her preference is
to not do that and and that's fine like
she has her own destiny and and her own
way of being in the world and there's
nothing to say that it's lesser in any
sense of the word at all
so should artists waste their time in
art school no you shouldn't waste your
time ever I think your question is is it
necessarily a waste of time to go to art
school and I would say it depends very
much on the art school and on what you
do while you're there if you go to art
school and you really work at it like
mad and you devote yourself to it and
you're in the library and you're
studying the great masters and you're
crafting your technique and you're at a
school where that's actually possible
then you can educate yourself and going
to art school can give you an identity
that allows you to investigate that
possibility free from undue social
pressure for some period of time which
is really the case with a an arts degree
or something like that as well so if you
can take advantage of it if you're
disciplined enough and if you can find a
school that isn't completely appallingly
postmodern and and social justice
oriented instead of oriented towards art
then I don't think it has to be a waste
of time but I think there's a high
probability that it will so serious
respectful question why did you have a
problem with Lindsay Shepard being
criticized for being non-critical but
you criticized faith Goldie for being
non-critical well the fundamental issue
I really listened carefully to faiths
interview the the interview that was
conducted I think with the daily stormer
I really listened to it and I sat down
and listened to it with my son whose
judgment I respect a lot and the thing
that differentiates the two is that
faith is a journalist and my sense was
that in this situation that she found
herself
it was incumbent on her as a journalist
to ask at least one or two probing
questions given the nature of the people
the known nature and the fact that she
knew the nature of the people that she
was talking to and I don't feel that she
did it and you know I was obviously not
alone in my assessment of that so her
employer who was very favorably
predisposed towards her also let her go
as a consequence of that and so I know
that and I've been accused of being
hypocritical as a consequence and I
should also say that the decision to
restructure the panel wasn't mine alone
it was actually well it was divided up
amongst the panel members essentially
but that's what we decided that's what
we decided and you know faith herself
had offered to bow out of the panel
because she knew that her presence would
be controversial in a way that might not
be productive
so whereas Lindsay was just a student
you know and and she was doing what she
was supposed to do now I'm not trying to
denigrate faith as a journalist in it
some general sense but you know
Charlottesville was very touchy and and
it was and it required an unbelievably
deft hand to go into that sort of rat's
nest and come out unscathed and you know
maybe we should thank kudos for her to
her for having the courage to even
attempt it but there's a difference
between it's not that easy to
distinguish between brave and foolhardy
and you know what they say well anyways
like I said we thought about it a lot I
listened to it a lot we made the
decision we made I'm not trying to say
that you know it was right in some
omniscient sense but I don't think that
the situation that Lindsay Sheppard
found herself in is sufficiently
comparable to that of faith to make the
question to make the comparison
fundamentally valid so Ethan beyond she
says I'm a Lib
hi hey Ethan you know I've considered
myself a liberal for a very long time
so welcome do you think I publicly
disassociate yourself enough with my
neo-nazi followers that you were that
use your work as justification for
violence and propaganda well you know
what kind of question is that
first of all you're you're making the
unwarranted assumption that I definitely
have neo-nazi followers followers you
know and that they use my work as a
justification and that they're engaged
in violence and propaganda it's like how
about a specific example or how about
ten specific examples you know I already
pointed out that imagine that so thirty
million people have watched my videos so
let's and 500,000 of them are youtube
subscribers so let's say I have 500,000
followers just for the sake of argument
okay like a thousand of them are going
to be completely out of their minds
because that's one in five hundred so
what does that prove you know you'd have
to demonstrate that there's a higher
rate than average of Pathology among the
people who claim in some manner to be my
followers you know you have to do that
because as I said everyone who's to the
right of the radical left is a group and
in that group there's going to be people
on the far right that doesn't mean
everyone in the group of non radical
leftists is a radical right winger
obviously so anyways you know I don't I
think that that's a loaded question
I think it's loaded in a bunch of ways
do you think you publicly dissociate
yourself enough well that's a loaded
question because the implication is is
that I don't publicly dissociate myself
enough then the next implication is that
I have more neo-nazi followers than a
random person with 500,000 followers
would have and then the next like loaded
bit is that they use my work as
justification I'd like to see that
happened because I can't see it how it
can possibly be used as just
vacation and that they use it for as a
justification for both propaganda and
violence it's like really come on that
you know maybe it's possible and if this
is the case I apologize it's possible
that you wrote that question because
you're favorably disposed towards me and
you know wanted to give me an
opportunity to address that question and
you know I can't tell but but it is
definitely the kind of question that
that the sort of journalists who've been
coming after me have been you know it's
like have you stopped beating your wife
yet it's like how are you gonna answer a
question like that you're losing their
way so okay well I think what I'm gonna
do I'm starting to run out of energy
here so I'm gonna read some of this okay
all right what the hell address the
Jewish Question that's a hell of a thing
to ask
so that's Jaqueline turn you know I mean
really that's a hell of a thing to ask
but I will say something about it you
know and I've thought about this a lot
so there is evidence that Ashkenazi Jews
so those are Jews of European heritage
have IQs that are about 15 points higher
than the population average so that's a
lot 15 points it's about the average
difference between the typical high
school student and the typical state
college student it's a lot and one of
the things that means is so imagine
there's two distributions and that they
overlap and that the Jewish one is is
the the mean is as one fifteen so the
whole distribution is shifted to the
right what that means is if you go up
into the higher IQ strata one 3145 way
the hell up there that Jewish people are
overwhelmingly over-represented at the
high end of the IQ distribution now the
price they pay for that is some
increased propensity for neurological
diseases that seems to be associated in
some sense with that heightened IQ now
you know the science on this isn't
settled but but it's reasonably solid
you know given the standards of such
things okay so Jews are gonna be
over-represented at the high end of
cognitively complex disciplines so then
I would say and that's the case like
their way over-represented among like
outstanding scientists and among Nobel
Prize winners and and so forth and so
you know people look and they think well
why are there a disproportionate number
of Jewish people in positions of
authority and they say well it must be a
conspiracy you know it must be systemic
in some sense it's like no it can be
simply accounted for by that relatively
large IQ differential
now the next criticism would be well
don't the Jews tend to lean left
well first you might say well you know
given what happened in in Nazi Germany
to the degree that that was right-wing
as we discussed earlier that's the
nationalism and ethnocentrism it's
hardly surprising that they might you
know in this historical period of time
tend to move towards the left but more
importantly than that IQ is associated
with trade openness and trade openness
is a strong predictor predictor of
political liberalism so and it's the
strongest predictor of political
liberalism so you know it's very
difficult so that's what I have to say
about that it's like and the other thing
I would say is you know the fact that
there's a population as sub population
of people who are much smarter than
average not on average right on average
I've you got to get that straight on
average is actually of great benefit to
the rest of us because what do you want
fewer geniuses fewer people with IQs of
145 or 160 that's and you know and it's
no conspiracy that puts people who are
smarter higher up in competence
hierarchies because IQs the best
predictor of movement up in a complex
called competence hierarchy so there
I've addressed the Jewish Question it's
like it's a confusion between ethnicity
and and IQ as far as I'm concerned so
I'll probably get like painted six
different shades of black for that
answer but it's I've thought about a
long time it's the best that I can
manage so ok I'm gonna read this oh one
more huckleberry says should I start
with past authoring if I am 40 I feel
that I have so many
solved issues from my past that prevents
me from accomplishing up my potential
from accomplishing my potential mostly
fear yes they the way that you wrote
that indicates very clearly that you
should do the past authoring first
because you already know that you have
unpleasant incidences incidents in your
past that are impairing your function so
alright so I'm gonna read I'm gonna read
this hopefully you can see that there's
an illustration there I'm gonna hold it
up so that I can see it there's a lag so
I don't know if it's in focus so give me
about ten seconds okay
okay so this is chapter four rule four
so the book has 12 rules in it the book
is called 12 rules for life and it's
published by penguin Random House and
it'll be out January 23rd and so this is
a book about this is chapter rule six
there's 12 rules hence the title and
they're taken from a subset of 42 rules
that I wrote for a Korra article called
what are the most important things that
everyone should know something like that
a very popular Korra article now the
illustration was done by Ethan Van
Sciver who's a comic book artist and a
good one so you can look up his work if
you want it's VA n SC IV ER ethan this
chapter is about the motivation behind
the actions of people like the Columbine
killers and the illustration is of a
very very criminally oriented individual
called named carl panzram you could look
him up PA and z ra m who was a very
resentful vicious violent destructive
and intelligent person because those
things can all go together so rule 6 is
called set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world and the
chapters all have little sub chapters so
the title of this subchapter is a
religious problem it does not seem
reasonable to describe the young man who
shot twenty children and six staff
members at Sandy Hook Elementary School
in Newton Connecticut in 2012 as a
religious person this is equally true
for the Colorado theater gunman and the
Columbine High School killer's but these
murderous individuals had a problem with
reality that existed at a religious
depth as one of the members of the
Columbine dual wrote the human race is
worth fighting for only worth killing
give the earth back to the animals they
deserve it infinitely more than we do
nothing means anything anymore people
who view people who think such things
view being itself as iniquity bull and
harsh to the point of corruption and
human being in particular as
contemptible they appoint themselves
supreme adjudicators of reality and find
it wanting they're the ultimate critics
the deeply cynical writer continues if
you recall your history the Nazis came
up with a quote final solution end quote
to the Jewish problem kill them all
well in case you haven't figured it out
I say kill mankind
no one should survive for such
individuals the world of experience is
insufficient and evil sort of hell with
everything what is happening when
someone comes to think in this manner a
great German play Faust a tragedy
written by Johann Wolfgang von Goethe
addresses that issue the play's main
character a scholar named Heinrich Faust
trades his immortal soul to the devil
mephistopheles in return he receives
whatever he desires while still alive on
earth and Gareth this play Memphis da
fleece is the eternal adversary of being
he has a central defining credo I am the
spirit who negates and rightly so for
all that comes to be deserves to perish
wretchedly were better nothing would
begin thus everything that you term sin
destruction and evil represent that's my
proper element dirt that considered this
hateful sentiment so important so key to
the central element of vengeful human
destructiveness the D ad Memphis da
Felice repeated a second time phrased
somewhat differently in part 2 of the
play written many years later people
think often in the Memphis to--they
liyan manner although they sell
act upon their thoughts as brutally as
the mass murderers of school college and
theater whenever we experience injustice
real or imagined whenever we encounter
tragedy or fall prey to the machination
z' of others whenever we experience the
horror and pain of our own apparently
arbitrary limitations the temptation to
question being and then to curse it
Rises Fowley from the darkness
why must innocent people suffer so
terribly what kind of bloody horrible
place is this anyways life is in truth
very hard everyone is destined for pain
and slated for destruction sometimes
suffering is clearly the result of
personal faults such as willful
blindness poor decision-making or
malevolence in such cases when it
appears to be self-inflicted it may even
seem just people get what they deserve
you might contend that's cold comfort
however even when true sometimes if
those who are suffering changed their
behavior then their lives would unfold
less tragically but human control is
limited susceptibility to despair
disease aging and death is universal and
the final analysis we do not appear to
be the architects of our own fragility
whose fault is it then people who are
very well ill or worse who have a sick
child will inevitably find themselves
asking this question whether they are
religious believers or not the same is
true of someone who finds his
shirtsleeve caught in the gears of a
giant bureaucracy who is suffering
through a tax audit or fighting an
interminable lawsuit or divorce and it's
not only the obviously suffering who are
tormented by the need to blame someone
or something for the intolerable state
of their being at the very height of his
fame influence and creative power for
example the towering leo tolstoy began
to question the value of human existence
he reasoned in this way my position was
terrible I knew that I could find
nothing in the way of rational no
College accepted denial of life and in
faith I could find nothing except the
denial of reason and this was even more
impossible than a denial of life
according to rational knowledge it
followed that life is evil people know
it they do not have to live yet they
have lived and they do live just as I
myself have lived even though I had
known for a long time that life is
meaningless and evil tries II might
Tolstoy could only identify four means
of escaping from such thoughts one was
retreating into childlike ignorance of
the problem another was pursuing
mindless pleasure
the third was continuing to drag out a
life that is evil and meaningless
knowing beforehand that nothing can come
of it he identified that particular form
of escape with weakness the people in
this category know that death is better
than life but they do not have the
strength to act rationally and quickly
put an end to the delusion by killing
themselves only the fourth and final
mode of escape involved open quote
strength and energy it consists of
destroying life once one has realized
that life is evil and meaningless close
quote
Tolstoy relentlessly followed his
thoughts only unusually strong and
logically consistent people act in this
manner
having realized all the stupidity of the
joke that is being played on us and
seeing that the blessings of the dead
are greater than those of the living and
that it is better not to exist they act
and put it into this stupid joke they
use any means of doing it a rope around
the neck water a knife in the heart a
train Tolstoy wasn't pessimistic enough
the stupidity of the joke being played
on us does not merely motivate suicide
it motivates murder mass murder often
followed by suicide that's a far more
effective existential protest by June of
2016 unbelievable as it may seem there
had been 1,000 mass killings to find his
four or more people shot in a single
incident excluding the shooter in the
u.s. in 1260 days
that's one such event on five of every
six days for more than three years
everyone says we don't understand how
can we still pretend that Tolstoy
understood more than a century ago the
ancient authors of the biblical story of
Cain and Abel understood as well more
than 20 centuries ago they described
murder as the first act of post identic
history and not just murder but
fratricidal murder and murder not only
of someone innocent but if someone ideal
and good had murdered unconsciously
despite the creator of the universe
today's killers tell us the same thing
in their own words who would dare say
that this is not the worm at the core of
the Apple but we will not listen because
the truth cuts too close to the bone
even for a mind as profound as that of
the celebrated Russian author there was
no way out
how can the rest of us manage when a man
of tolstoy stature admits defeat for
years he hid his guns from himself and
would not walk with a rope in his hand
and Casey hanged himself how can a
person who is awake avoid outrage at the
world the next sub chapter is called
vengeance or transformation well and the
rest of the Trapster chapter attempts to
answer the questions that I posed in
that beginning and hopefully I've
managed it at least in some small way
anyways that's a bit from one chapter of
this book 12 rules for life an antidote
to chaos it comes out January 23rd it's
available for pre-order for those of you
who might be interested on amazon.com
and amazon.ca and it's quite heavily
discounted at the moment I think it's
50% off on the Canadian site and 35% off
on the American site maybe I'll put a
link in the description I hope that the
book is helpful
I put a lot of work into it and I think
it's advanced my thinking quite a bit
and and I think it's readable I've a lot
of people have looked at it now and I've
had good editors and so on and I think
that I tried to make it as accessible as
possible I mean it deals with ideas that
are pretty sophisticated but I'm hoping
I got the balance between complexity and
and sophistication and ease of access
right ties I certainly hope so and I
hope it's kind of poetic you know
because I tried to make each sentence
scan properly and have a rhythm and all
of that anyways my wife has made
Thanksgiving it's not Canadian
Thanksgiving it's American Thanksgiving
but we celebrate both of them because my
son is American and we lived in the
States for quite a few years so I'm
gonna go and see my grandkid and my son
and my daughter and all the other people
that are around me thank God and thanks
for listening guys and for being
interested in I hope you get your acts
together and fix up the world til next
time bye-bye